consider yourselves traditional women no
no no
okay do you guys want traditional
relationships or no no okay so you're
good with the 50s you want 50 50 the
bills a 100
100. I'm saying what do you mean you're
both paying 100 you want to live in
separate houses
how is this gonna work
well how is this gonna work
how do I put this I don't know
yeah okay you know what it should be 50
50 right it should be
actually right now for me the comment
for me it should be hundred hundred
because you know they expect the woman
to be at home looking after the kids and
also work also work from my point of
view you have to work as well you know
they put that pressure on you for you to
go to work because they're not the
building's not making sense zombie
Housewives right yeah some be Housewives
but I'm talking like from my point of
view you know I mean like in my
situation I'm working I'm also looking
after the kids I'm doing everything do
you get what I mean but he just goes to
work comes back um so you both work
basically okay but it's like when it
comes to the children so who watches the
kids when you you're at work you have to
go to Nursery oh they go to they go to
daycare now they're grown now but before
that I was doing slowly you're 20 so how
old are your kids
I've got a chair old and a six-year-old
oh they're not grown they aren't grown
my daughter is 10 so I've got three like
I said my oldest is ten she'll be 11
this year not looking forward to it at
all and then I've got an eight-year-old
and an almost two-year-old yeah crazy
the youngest
Red Bull so I I have a question for you
um how because I always wonder this like
with like people that send their kids to
Nursery do you worry about them having
more influence on your children than you
will I do yeah but at the same time it's
like if I have to sacrifice something to
gain something you know if if they're at
home with me
I can't put food on the table yeah as
well you know I don't wanna have to deal
with the extra garbage and the stress
and all that so however work you know
baby go to Nursery I'll spend time with
you when you come back home if you're
tired it's okay weekend I'll try and
make some time for you and you guys
couldn't survive off of one income is
what you're saying okay especially you
know like the whole covered and
everything is it was just ridiculous and
having to move to Birmingham is oh
ridiculous so why um I think blessing
joined the show because you said
something about Zim culture you're not a
fan of I'm against him so what what do
you not like about this you're gonna
have them coming from my neck
wow this is about to get heated mirror
Zimbabwe no I would never date marry a
Zimbabwe and I've never dated as a
mother man I never will look at one why
they are just
yeah why I was just leave it there let
me not say anything to me they say if I
have nothing anything nice to say don't
say anything at all right is that
because of an ex or no it's just I don't
really want to put my past too much into
this but it's just the way I was raised
you know my father is obviously
Zimbabwean and the things I went through
you're dead to a certain extent
but I love him now
why now
because I feel like he's paying for
everything he's on to me
what
did he what did he do
well when I was young well not too young
when I was like 17 years old he did
throw me out
and that really hurt
it threw me out because of his wife
that's not my mom
and I was going through so much trauma
I was very suicidal in that time and I
felt like I will shut up
and what what caused you to get thrown
out like was it a fight it was a petty
fight that
paused
that caused me to get for now and you
had no part to play in the fight
I did say something that was wrong okay
now that I look back
because I was trying to find out about
my mom you know I used to ask him about
my mom oh tell me about my mom and he
was just saying you know she left you
and that didn't sit right with me
because the fact with my mom's family
was telling me different you know so I
just wanted to know from him like you're
my father tell me about her and
that day even though he was so angry at
me I'm gonna explain everything that
happened in the moment but he was so
angry to the point where I said you're
trying to kick me out just like you did
to my mom and that's what made him
really get extremely angry and I was not
wrong I was right yeah but the way you
tell the story you act like it was all
him and nothing like you didn't do
anything and this prose I feel like I
blazing myself like yeah you have a part
to play yeah like everyone does I should
have never said anything to him
[Music]
but do you think it was time for me to
say something because that whole you
know mental abuse from
his wife and him it was too much like
mental abuse I'm not gonna explain
exactly everything because I don't need
to say that you know but there's certain
things that
have put me through even from when I was
younger well it's just like mentally
that's like a pretty severe accusation
you know it was yeah it was really bad
but I don't want to stay because I know
if certain people see this they don't
want to like that so I'll just leave it
and so because he because he kicked out
he kicked you out at 17 in a fight that
you guys like both had a part to plan
would you admit now she created it you
said you would you shouldn't have said
anything right I shouldn't have said
anything to him actually just kept it
directly to her because she was the one
that had an issue with me
the whole time but because he acted out
of anger based on whatever he told him
in that moment he was angry at me and I
was also angry I had the right to say
whatever I say you know I'm only human
you think you have the right to say
anything because you're angry I mean I
didn't swear at him
yeah you know that's disrespectful and
my point is yeah but if it was if
someone is shoving you out the house and
throwing your things out the window what
are you gonna do what are you everything
yeah you're not gonna stand you're not
gonna stand there you cannot everything
just kind of came to me like wow so the
way you threw my mom out is exactly the
same way you're doing to me wait did
this happen here or in Zimbabwe in the
UK
but with her yeah with her yeah in the
UK but why is it like a zoom cultures
for if it's just your situation because
all the men in my family are trash
yeah all of them but I think it's as
well that she's been through a lot when
it comes to like the men in her family
so it's just made her
think that way
no I mean I I know um like grape victims
that don't view men a certain way like
you can go through things like that's
like saying if one guy got cheated on by
a woman and saying all women cheat
so it's like you're throwing out an
entire culture what I mean by
certain people have come across us oh I
was involved one have really tried to
torment my life for me sounds like uh if
you're the common denominator it sounds
like a respect issue because at 17 and
I've got siblings who are Zimbabwean and
I know like a zim household is built on
respect respecting the illnesses
expecting their parents would you say in
that situation where you were respectful
to your parents How can I
not say anything so you wanted me to
keep shutting myself out keep taking
pills to do essay on myself like
literally to commit suicide you wanted
me to carry and do that instead of me
speaking out that was the first time
I've ever spoken out to my dad yeah but
what did she do that was so like
insanely better she was angry she was
going through her own personal issues
obviously she's got whatever she needs
to take for to help her out with her
mental health I understand that now
then they never told me that they never
told me that she had an issue with her
mental health and that's the reason why
she used to treat me really badly you
know there's been so many things that
happened between me and her to the point
where she even warned me that she wanted
to get rid of me she told me how old did
you like your dad have like a bring it
in
um
from like 15 was it 15 when I left slow
your time
yeah 15. yeah do you not think it's like
um a teenage kind of like just teenage
emotions because it sounds to me like
you just lashing out like you know my
mom and she was just not having that my
mother was dead from when I was 10 years
old so that's got nothing to do with my
mother
but when she's coming into a role of
like literally becoming like a mother in
the house she never treated me like her
daughter she told me I'm not you're not
my daughter I'll never call me
mom
oh damn and I tried to buy her love
because I never really had love from any
of the women that were in my father's
life
I would do the most I'll buy gifts I'll
I'll cook this I'll clean this do you
know what I mean what was your
relationship with your dad before that
it was amazing so why didn't you find
like like you could communicate with
them why didn't you not do that straight
away because of her um I don't know but
it's like what I hear though because I
had no part to play in it and it's sort
of like a victim mentality it's like
they did everything wrong I did nothing
wrong but they that's the that's the
part though they did do wrong to me they
might have done wrong but I just think
in most situations like you can look
back and say I had a part to play what
did that play when I was younger than
them and they're grown adults I mean I I
can you know I'll use it but try not no
I know what you're gonna do yeah
I'm saying when I when I was a kid like
I didn't think I absolutely did things
that contributed to say that you have no
accountability just because you're
underage like that's the silliest thing
I've ever heard I I absolutely did
things that contributed to fights with
my parents okay for example let's say
you come back from college right a long
day I'll totally cook this okay fine
I'll cook it I'll clean this I'll cook
it I clean it I do have a house she's
telling me to do right
just one thing I forgot to do bear in
mind I've got work to do as well I've
got homework to do I've done everything
she said I need to do oh but you forgot
to do this yeah but that's just typical
that's just typical yeah but what she
would do she would not create the issue
from that yeah she goes my dad like oh
can you imagine she never did this and
she'll purposely mess up the yard let's
mess up the house
and make it seem like I didn't do
anything that's that's what I started
thinking that raw that's a bit weird now
that's crazy that is weird and the part
when she thought I was dressing up in a
specific way for my father who said same
to me I was dressing up for my father
that's that's why I was like no there's
something wrong with her but then my dad
never told me like oh she's got a mental
issue but if he did I probably would
have understood like okay you know what
maybe let me be a bit more sensitive let
me not feel some type of way when she
does certain things but because he never
did another time she touched me you know
beating me and all that stuff police
code and everything
that wouldn't have happened if there was
certain things put in place for her not
to even react like that towards me
because I don't understand why the angle
was so much towards me yeah this story
is just this story just seems very crazy
like it's like so she was messing up the
yard and then we like it was so bad to
the point where I started feeling like
you know when you get to a point where
you say you know what I'm done and then
you're like taking pills because you're
like I've had enough and the person is
telling you I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something to you like they're taking
certain things I'm not gonna say what it
is but
and then they're standing in the Church
of praising God and the person who's
gonna be giving you like dirty looks I
didn't feel comfortable anywhere I
wouldn't accept College literally at
school
literally as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible